[Applause]
so tell us how you use this kind of
drawing this image when you were doing
your interviews yes so this was a
drawing that helped start a conversation
about alpha and abnormalities of muskox
ins for example here in the eyes in the
nose or mouth or any change over time in
terms of behavior or body condition and
this is the cedars word in english and
in renekton so i use it a few times when
i interview participants that were not
fluent in english but i would have
always a translator and interpreter with
me but having a visual tool will help a
lot the conversation and to point to
where they see point on the animal to
where there seemed lesion or differences
so this is the outside what about for
the inside of the animal yeah for the
inside we would have another muskoxen
that's shown a very simple drawing of
the inside of the animal soul you have
the different organs and it was the same
pattern so asking if they've seen any
lesion in the different organs and you
can see the lungs the heart the kidney
and the spleen and where they are placed
in their masters in a very simple way
but having it visualized and in a
drawing would make the conversation
easier so they would be able to say oh
we saw lesions here or we yeah Ryan to
in the different organs it was a one of
the visual tool that was very helpful in
my research
[Music]